Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, take a listen to
this voicemail from a guy who's just throwing out
all the right wing MAGA red meat. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: And go on to say David
Pack boys are better than you know.
Speaker 1: What he's saying is David
Pack boy is a beta male. Thank you.
Speaker 4: And Trump 2024.
Speaker 1:
Okay, well, vote for the guy. Go ahead.
Speaker 4: Jesse Lee Peterson's
an alpha male and he's innocent.
Speaker 1: And you know, Jesse Lee Peterson
hasn't to say Jesse Peterson is innocent. People
have come out and said, Jesse Lee Peterson's gay.
I don't know that innocent is necessarily the
right term. Yes, he's accused of making advances,
but the term innocence is a weird term to use.
Speaker 4: Joe Biden. Hunter Biden. Prison 2023.
Speaker 1: That's a bet I would be
willing to take. I am not a betting man,
but if someone wants to bet, even odds do Hunter
or Joe Biden end up in prison in 2023? I will
take the No. And whatever stakes you've got later.
Yeah, later. This is pretty significant brain rot.
But unfortunately, at least some of these people
vote. It's important we all be registered and we
all participate. I have something super exciting
to announce to you next Friday, December 23rd. We
have never done something like this before. We are
going to be doing our end of the year membership
drive. Oh, David, but you've done that before.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves.
Speaker 1: No, no, no, no, no. This is different.
Okay. Our end of the year membership drive. It'll
be a one day event. Friday, December 23.
It'll be beautifully timed right before
Christmas and during Hanukkah. It's going to be
fantastic. It's going to be really, really good,
open to everybody. Whatever you celebrate or
don't celebrate one day. Membership drive.
The first month's payment. For people who sign
up on that day using the special coupon code
is going to be donated and then matched and
doubled. And we are going to be doing this
through GiveDirectly, which actually gives cash
to people in extreme poverty. Widely known now the
best way to really build industry and community
and allow people to determine for themselves how
best to improve their lives. You don't send
shoes. You give cash. Okay. So this is super,
super exciting. Friday, December 23. It's going to
be a membership drive with a great discount code
so you can get a membership. But then that first
payment, if you pay monthly, it'll be your first
payment. If you pay yearly, will take a 12th of
it. Your first month's membership payment. We're
not keeping. We will donate and then double
it. Okay. I have no idea whether this will
do well or whether it won't. We've never done
anything like it before. But I would love for
you to participate. It's really easy. Get on my
mailing list at David Pakman dot com. Just get
on the mailing list. Friday, December 23rd. You'll
get an email telling you, here's the coupon code,
you sign up, you get the membership, we donate
that first payment and double it. Donate and
double, double it. Unbelievable stuff. Excited to
do it. Last thing, we've got a great bonus show
for you today. We're going to talk about the new
plan to ban tick tock, the plan to ban tick tock
in the U.S. Secondly, we've learned that Brett
Kavanaugh hangs out with Matt Gaetz. Why? What are
they doing? Is it appropriate? It's not. And we
will talk about the pandemic border entry limits
on migrants being set to end next week. What are
the implications? What are the speculations? All
of that and more on today's bonus show. Sign up
at join pacman dot com and get instant access.